[Música]
hola bienvenidos a el debate de france
24 soy santiago lópez gonzález luis ar
se cumplió su primer año como presidente
de bolivia un año que comenzó con un
llamado a la unidad tras un remezón
político que vivió en ese país
suramericano en el 2019 que llevó a un
gobierno interino al poder y a la
renuncia del ex presidente evo morales
un año también marcado por la crisis de
la pandemia y por todo lo que esto trae
la crisis social la crisis hospitalaria
la crisis económica y la presión que
normalmente recae sobre el gobierno de
turno en cualquier país del mundo que
está padeciendo esta pandemia de kobe 19
además este primer año de gobierno se
cumple empañado por una huelga nacional
indefinida entre los organizadores están
los comités cívicos regionales que
tuvieron un papel muy destacado en las
manifestaciones del 2019 que llevaron
como ya decía a la salida del ex
presidente evo morales a ellos se
sumaron otros sectores como los llamados
gremiales y también los transportistas
pero también varios ciudadanos del común
que expresaron su descontento por la ley
13 86 de estrategia nacional contra la
legitimación de las ganancias ilegales
que la oposición ha usado como un
instrumento para fundamentar y para
entregar un discurso que desde su
perspectiva
vulnera la constitución de ese país
también atenta contra la propiedad
privada y le da digamos herramientas al
estado boliviano para intervenir por
simple sospecha en cuentas bancarias o
en las comunicaciones de algunos
ciudadanos para iniciar procesos
mientras que desde el gobierno promueven
esta ley como una necesidad para
actualizar la legislación contra los
delitos financieros y así cumplir con
estándares y compromisos internacionales
pues como ya ven este es el panorama que
se está presentando en bolivia a grandes
rasgos vamos a profundizar y para ello
hemos invitado a fernando sanz martín
carrasco ella es abogada también ex
diputada por el partido opositor unidad
democrática se encuentra en la ciudad de
la paz ahí en el altiplano y también
está con nosotros jose hugo moldíz él es
escritor e investigador ex ministro de
gobierno de bolivia durante la
administración del ex presidente evo
morales también se encuentra allí en la
ciudad de la paz ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
por supuesto estamos en facebook en
instagram y en twitter síganos como
france24
bajo ese santi logo les recuerdo nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
estamos ahí pendientes de todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales pues yo quiero
comenzar con fernanda en la ciudad de la
paz
preguntándole sobre este mensaje de
unidad
era tal vez la bandera de eloy
presidente luís arse en el momento en
que asumió la presidencia él asumió en
un país muy polarizado como ya lo decía
después de un proceso electoral muy
complejo muy complicado que tanto ha
logrado unir a los bolivianos a lo largo
de este año cómo está la situación allí
en el país
buenas noches a todos y todos gracias
por la invitación santiago mira al
contrario yo creo que ese discurso de
reconciliación ha sido un discurso de
reconciliación para las bases del
movimiento al socialismo no ha sido un
discurso de reconciliación hacia afuera
hacia los ciudadanos en general
efectivamente dentro del más había
muchas y hay todavía muchas fracciones
que han sufrido también una crisis
profunda política y creo que ese mensaje
estaba más hacia volcado hacia ese ese
tipo de audiencia hacia la población en
general
el presidente luís arse lo que ha hecho
ha sido más bien polarizar aún más la
situación entre esa dicotomía que
siempre hace el movimiento socialismo
entre los buenos y los malos los
vendepatrias según ellos y los que están
del lado del pueblo cuando en realidad
lo utilizan con un argumento político
para conseguir fines partidarios de esta
polarización en una persecución política
judicial izada de manera grosera
con varios casos que se han abierto de
ex autoridades
durante los gobiernos de transición que
obviamente más allá del tema de que
exista o no existe corrupción porque
efectivamente ha existido corrupción
también en el en el gobierno de
transición no significa que no se debe
respetar debido proceso' que no se deben
respetar garantías constitucionales que
en este caso no se está garantizando y
que el poder judicial es otra vez
utilizado como instrumento de presión
política hacia el disidente hacia el
opositor y eso junto con una reforma de
justicia que no ha existido por lo tanto
refuerza ese carácter de la justicia
simplemente instrumentalizada
también hay en la ciudad de la paz hugo
moldíz en buenas noches de hago la misma
pregunta que usted que el presidente dar
se ha logrado cumplir en este primer año
por lo menos mejorar esa situación de
polarización y unir un poco más a los
bolivianos después de este escenario tan
complejo políticamente y social que
estaban padeciendo como lo vio usted
buena noches santiago gusto estar aquí
con maría fernanda a ver
depende siempre desde donde se miran las
cosas
el país estaba en una crisis política
derivada de un golpe de estado en 2019
y una crisis económica y una crisis
sanitaria y ese y esa crisis política
empezó a ser resuelta por la vía
electoral en esa vía electoral un 50 y
5.1 por ciento voto por el movimiento al
socialismo por su binomio que pretendía
ser
proscrito y también durante el año 2020
ojalá palabras como las de maría
fernanda si hubieran escuchado en aquel
momento donde el señor murillo y el
señor ministro de defensa
los
perseguían masacraban y empujaban a más
de
1500 personas a buscar exilio por
ejemplo en argentina
a quienes no se les respecto al debido
proceso ni nada por el estilo pero bueno
volvamos a la coyuntura
la unidad no es un hecho romántico la
unidad se construye por todos los
actores y ciertamente en una coyuntura
política
posterior a la recuperación de la
democracia quedan heridas y esas heridas
tiene que tratar de ser resueltas
paralelamente se van generando
condiciones de una nueva unidad nacional
unidad nadal nacional no quiere decir ni
olvido ni perdón' unidad nacional quiere
decir poner las cosas en su lugar
generar procesos de crítica autocrítica
y de reflexión y creo que la oposición
como lo está demostrando por ejemplo y
con un pretendido paro nacional y ahí sí
quiero decirle santiago que de
nacionales se paró no tiene nada es un
paro básicamente en el departamento de
santa cruz epicentro de la oposición y
al presidente evo morales 6 no cuando
cuando cuando la oposición plantea los
bochornos que ayer sucedieron en la
asamblea legislativa plurinacional
cuando en vez de plantear el diálogo lo
que plantea es el conflicto y la
violencia es evidente que la oposición
no quiere ni unidad ni diálogo ni mucho
menos democracia maria fernanda algo que
decir al respecto y antes de que me
responda quiero remitirme a esos hechos
que sucedieron precisamente allí en el
hemiciclo en bolivia durante la lectura
de esta rendición de cuentas del primer
año del presidente arts en donde hubo
abucheos y silbatos
claramente esto muestra la tensión que
hay entre los diferentes partidos
políticos que hay allí en bolivia es
saludable para la democracia boliviana
este tipo de hechos es saludable el
trato que ha recibido el presidente en
la lectura de su informe
ese ejemplo también para la sociedad y
luego analizamos un poco de lo que él
dijo a lo largo de su informe maria
fernanda
bueno yo creo que no es saludable para
ninguna democracia el enfrentamiento de
ningún lado y creo que ambas
partes tanto oposición como oficialismo
deberían reflexionar sobre el tema
porque creo que las imágenes son claras
y ceden
legisladores
de oficio del oficialismo empujó negando
y pegando a mujeres de oposición de
legisladores de oposición en un claro y
franco acoso y de violencia política
ahora creo que él cuando dice hugo
moldíz que se persiguen masacraba bueno
estoy de acuerdo muy bien habrá que
instalar un debido proceso para que lo
que ha ocurrido en el gobierno de
transición sea también juzgado en su
correcta dimensión pero eso no le
significa que les da carta blanca para
hacer exactamente lo mismo ahora en un
tono de revanchismo como lo ha hecho en
sus declaraciones el propio
vicepresidente de choquehuanca que
mandaba desbloquear a la fuerza
a este paro indefinido que se ha llamado
como quiere minimizarlo muchas para
muchos personeros y voceros del gobierno
pero sin embargo ha parado la
las actividades en la mayor parte del
país y sobre todo creo que ahí lo que ha
habido que evita esta unificación del
país es la actitud de la policía a mando
por supuesto del gobierno de dejarse de
reprimir de una manera
desarmada de una manera absolutamente
desmedida y desproporcionada a
ciudadanos que estaban en las calles
protestando se ve como incluso a mujeres
y personas mayores se les reprime con
gas de una forma que realmente dista
mucho del discurso de supuesta
reconciliación que tiene alce
señor hugo moldíz también allí en la paz
le pregunto entonces este año que se
cumple claramente ha habido
manifestaciones a lo largo de estos
meses y ha habido manifestaciones
justo que coinciden con el aniversario
de este primer año del presidente arts
en el poder como evaluar este
descontento ciudadano usted desde su
perspectiva dice que no ha habido
grandes manifestaciones pero siete de
las grandes capitales o de las capitales
de los nueve departamentos de bolivia
tuvieron problemas con las marchas hubo
gente manifestándose y hubo problemas en
el tránsito y así no llegaron las
imágenes de lo que vimos estando fuera
desde bolivia pero usted que está allí
que nos dice
si no sé de dónde les llegarán a ustedes
la información a ver medios bolivianos
si habrá que ver qué medios bolivianos a
ver este yo voy a tratar de hacerlo más
objetivo porque no hay peor cosa que
engañarse a sí mismo santacruz sigue
siendo la plaza más adversa a un
gobierno popular y de izquierda
en bolivia no hay que negar eso esa es
una realidad
ahí hay una disputa entre por ejemplo el
partido en el que militaba o milita la
señora maria fernanda y el partido
creemos que más es de más de
ultraderecha no que son casi hegemónicos
en el departamento ser es más no deja de
ser una fuerza interesante pero no la
fuerza realmente
en cochabamba se ha bloqueado
básicamente en el norte decir por el
lado de acá la cara en el sur de la
ciudad de cochabamba nada en la paz ha
habido una marcha que no es lo mismo que
bloqueo de una parte de los gremialistas
en tarija también es sólo en el casco
urbano en potosí si ha habido una
movilización más o menos importante más
que bloqueo movilización porque lo que
se llama un paro ya un bloqueo
luego en chuquisaca casi prácticamente
nada en fin así que habría que matizar
eso
para no dar la sensación porque estamos
hablando de un medio serio como el de
ustedes de que prácticamente el gobierno
está acorralado en firmaron que está
enfrentando un momento dicho que el
gobierno está acorralado y creo que hay
una mala interpretación de la palabra
bloqueo cuando yo digo bloqueo es que
salieron a las calles y el tránsito pues
se vio bloqueado por las manifestaciones
en ningún momento de hecho que la ciudad
haya colapsado o que el gobierno está
acorralada en un país donde siempre hay
conflicto en mi querido santiago siempre
hay manchas de todos los días es parte
de la cotidianidad
boliviana entonces
ustedes han criminalizado mientras que
cuando el más salí en protestas
fernanda pues puede decir su punto de
vista adelante hugo el
jugo dejemos que maría fernanda de su
punto de vista para para para confrontar
aquí las ideas a ver qué podemos sacar
de conclusión está bien hable usted
entonces santiago
y estaba hablando yo he servido en esta
zona la palabra a mí
hugo yo creo que el decir que siempre
han habido marchas
y cuando sale la ministra de la
presidencia es decir cuántos se pierden
de millones de dólares con las marchas
cuando sin embargo el más bloqueada
antes de ser gobierno contra partido de
oposición cuando bloqueaba cuando hacía
inviable en el país ahí no había ninguna
ningún argumento ni justificación
económica que pueda disuadir de las
marchas entonces también es si vamos a
hacer serios pues digamos las cosas
también desde un punto de vista objetivo
no simplemente desde esa desde ese afán
de buscar justificar la posición
política como sea
maría fernanda justo que coincida este
paro o estas manifestaciones como
ustedes lo quieran llamar de acuerdo a
su punto de vista que coincidan con este
primer aniversario del presidente desde
la parte oficial por ejemplo la
viceministra de comunicación de bolivia
gabriel a alcohol decía que este paro no
tiene argumentos y añadió que todos los
temas que están siendo reclamados por
los ciudadanos están siendo atendidos
por el gobierno como lo ve usted y qué
tan disiente es que hayan salido los
gremialistas transportistas que sean los
que han salido en estas en estas
concentrado en estas marchas
hay un motivo que es la ley de
enriquecimiento de ganancias ilícitas en
el cual busca el gobierno de dejarse
tener la carta blanca para poder
intervenir cuentas sin necesidad de un
proceso judicial
previo a dar dar una carta blanca para
que efectivamente se
pueda hacer una persecución política más
de la que ya se está haciendo
entonces el entrar a cuentas sin tener
una orden judicial el investigar y el
bien pinchar teléfonos sin tener un
orden judicial lo que está haciendo es
criminalizar prácticamente a toda la
población
presumiendo que sus ganancias son
ilícitas en un país además donde el 85
por ciento de la economía es una
economía informal entonces obviamente en
los gremialistas son los primeros
afectados porque sienten que esto va a
atentar contra su modo de vida contra
ganarse el pan de cada día y que son
parte de desde el pueblo no van a decir
que es la oligarquía con con la que está
saliendo a las calles ni que es la
oposición
clásica que está saliendo en las calles
hugo que tan importante es para el
gobierno sacar adelante esta ley con la
que ya lleva varios meses
batallando hemos visto a funcionarios
del gobierno del gobierno
entregando la información aclarando
puntos aclarando dudas sobre esta ley
que ha le ha costado tanto promover y
que por lo menos la gente entienda cuál
es la necesidad o entienda cuál es el
punto de vista para promoverla desde el
partido desde el partido no desde el
gobierno
la oligarquía nunca sale a las calles
siempre empuja a los sectores más
atrasados del campo popular pero bien
santiago la ley fue retirada y lo que
queda es otra ley la 13 86 que
prácticamente es inaplicable sin la
aprobación de la ley retirada si le doy
un ejemplo en la estrategia nacional de
lucha contra la legitimación de
ganancias ilícitas y financiamiento al
terrorismo en la que me imagino estamos
todos de acuerdo
además le
acusaban de querer uno proteger las
ganancias ilícitas y segundo de encubrir
al terrorismo no no no entiendo el
razonamiento de hoy de la oposición que
no sea el de oponerse a cualquier cosa
pero bien en uno de los artículos de la
ley vigente 386 y establece la creación
del consejo
en ese consejo que iba a ser multi
sectorial multi institucional se iban a
llevar adelante
no es verdad que sean procesos y que no
se ajusten a la ley a la constitución
sino tiene que ver con los estándares
usted lo ha dicho una introducción a la
entrevista con los estándares mundiales
que tienen que ver con convenios de
carácter mundial naciones unidas en la
caf y etcétera etcétera no y todos estos
son bastantes expertos os de convenios y
tratados internacionales sino en los
primeros en gritar serían las naciones
unidas los eeuu cuando no en fin
entonces pero bueno a lo que me voy es
que es en este momento injustificado una
movilización porque esa ley la ley ya
específica fue retirada de con su
consideración el gobierno ha dicho que
no la va a poner nuevamente en el tema y
la ley que está vigente que es la 13 86
es inaplicable sin la segunda
porque ya no hay consejo ya no hay nada
no hay fe ni un agente que pueda regular
que pueda normar y que por lo cuanto
pueda aplicar una determinada sanción
contra las ganancias ahora eso quiere
decir que el país está con incumpliendo
con convenios internacionales no
necesariamente con el término santiago
en el país hay muchas normas que están
sueltas y una de las ideas era
concentrar esas normas sueltas
fragmentadas en una sola para después
cumplir con estos con esta lucha contra
las ganancias ilícitas pero si la ley ya
fue
derogada porque siguen saliendo a las
calles entonces los ciudadanos
por eso hay una hay una que está vigente
que prácticamente es inaplicable
heroína aplicada en la segunda hora
porque están saliendo
cuando uno ve las declaraciones del
señor calvo
si ustedes también seguramente lo han
debido a leer ya poner en un segundo
plano el tema de la ley y dice estamos
peleando contra la dictadura y por la
democracia algo con más o menos dijeron
lo mismo el 2019 una oposición que ni
junta llega al 50 por ciento no entonces
que también es desconocer la voluntad
popular de una mayoría que no se está
por la derecha pero que si vota por el
pueblo entonces si no esto continuar
santiago hay que estar prevenidos de que
esto va a continuar en bolivia hay una
que es bien distinta un oasis poderosa
institución me pregunto yo me pregunto
hubo le pregunto a uno si entonces dices
que es la ley 13 86 es inaplicable
porque no tiene la segunda ley que
estaba por aprobar sí que el final de
cuentas no se aprobó entonces porque
simplemente no desarticulan todo el
movimiento que está en las calles todo
el paro indefinido y agroganadero en las
y no hay ninguna aplicabilidad si no
tiene ningún sentido y está vacía de su
sentido la norma eso no es cierto
entonces cuál qué es lo que no es cierto
esa ley también atenta contra el
principio básico de la presunción de
inocencia cuarta la libertad la igualdad
pero si ustedes dicen que no es ni
aplicable entonces bueno pues entonces
cuál es creo que hay una falta de
escucha por parte del gobierno de
simplemente agarrar pedir al legislativo
que drogas sale que es inaplicable y no
tienes era viejo que dice ese al
respecto y por favor sean puntuales
porque tengo que avanzar con otros temas
que tengo para preguntarle hacia
adelante que dice usted al respecto
sabes bien que le han dicho retire la 13
86 retire la ley de ascenso retire esto
se tire esto se tire esto por favor
principal
el gobierno políticamente tomó esa
decisión y yo leo no es cierto esa
decisión de no retroceder más por un
principio de autoridad porque si no
vienes no retrocede por capricho por no
escuchar a la gente
sin
tocar porque la oposición que es
minoritaria no va a ejercer una
dictadura desde la asamblea en este país
a mi gente democracia hugo la democracia
es ley y de respeto a los derechos de
las minorías también por si no sabes
andar realizar un poquito eso es término
democracia es el respeto del derecho de
la semana a las minorías y por último
también tiene el derecho de manifestarse
y tiene el derecho de pedir esta ley se
les respete el derecho a la isleta de la
bilis que dentón todos ellos me maría
fernanda que al parecer le falta leerlos
porque así como hay de expertos
está bien hay el respeto a las mayorías
si hay una relación minoría mayorías en
la democracia
una mirada dale una mirada a los
derechos humanos de repente eso te va a
servir un tratado básico
tengo que avanzar con otros temas que
tengo para analizar con ustedes me
quiere analizar el tema de la economía
fernando
es tal vez uno de los puntos que el
presidente trató de destacar ayer en su
discurso en allí en el hemiciclo
él fue el ministro de economía durante
la administración de evo morales y
destacó que en su gestión la economía ha
crecido un 9.3 por ciento en este primer
semestre del 2021 recuperando también
reservas internacionales gestionando la
pandemia del cob y 19 que es otro tema
que ya vamos a analizar más adelante y
la compra de las vacunas su balance del
tema económico en bolivia en este ancho
germán bueno primero yo creo que voy a
empezar con el punto positivo porque yo
creo que había un punto positivo en la
gestión de arte se ha ahorrado
muchísimos millones de dólares en
propaganda política durante 14 años el
movimiento socialismo estaba
acostumbrado a invertir ingentes
cantidades de dinero de recursos
económicos que provenían de dinero
público en esa imagen mesiánica que
tenía evo morales y que felizmente el
presidente ar se ha cortado con esos
gastos millonarios son gastos mucho más
modestos y creo que eso es un ahorro
interesante para el país en términos de
priorizar
en la agenda económica segundo en el
tema del crecimiento económico primero
que ver el crecimiento
que ha crecido y cómo ha crecido ha
habido un crecimiento pero no nos
olvidemos que venimos de cifras
negativas de un año con unas cuarentena
con una pandemia mundial que el mundo
entero entrado en recesión y obviamente
ha habido un crecimiento
gracias a que poco a poco se está
saliendo de esta pandemia
ahora si vemos el pib de desde junio del
2020 a julio del 2021 vemos que ha
crecido solamente un 1 43 por ciento con
lo cual además eso significa que no
existiría el doble aguinaldo extraño en
el crecimiento hay 12 sectores que han
crecido sobre sobre todo minería y
construcción del 30 al 50 por ciento que
son los sectores y además que responden
esta matriz económica está activista de
de que la izquierda no tiene nada que
son absolutamente de derecha y otros
sectores que han crecido casi nada casi
menos del 1 por ciento como el caso de
turismo gastronomía y servicios pues hay
un crecimiento desigual aunque
efectivamente no está siendo suficiente
y no hay políticas ni de empleo ni de
recuperación económica real a mediano y
largo plazo hugo sus impresiones sobre
este balance económico
después de escuchar esa gran concesión
que hace al gobierno de arce bueno a ver
durante el gobierno de facto no se
invirtió en este país absolutamente nada
y la inversión pública en países como
los nuestros es fundamental
ojalá la señora que se hubiera invertir
por lo menos la cuarta parte
llegamos a tener una contracción
económica que se estimaba que era del
11% pero ya los datos oficiales
establecen un 8.8 por ciento de
contracción de la economía hoy vamos a
llegar a fin de año a sobrepasar el
crecimiento del 5 por ciento según datos
del banco mundial fondo monetario
internacional en bolivia no será todavía
es la primera economía en la en la
región sudamericana como lo fue en los
últimos 7 años antes del golpe de estado
es la que será la tercera no va a ver
evidentemente doblar en alto porque se
mide entre junio y junio
y eso no es imposible porque
prácticamente el nuevo crecimiento sino
hábil de crecimiento durante el gobierno
de facto hay una inversión que va a
llegar hasta el fin de año de más de 4
mil millones de dólares es decir haré
para no dispersar nos sí en favor
concreto en la recta final sin países
como los nuestros no solamente es el
producto de los precios de las materias
primas internacionales sino el mercado
interno y ese mercado interno funciona
en la medida que existe una gran
inversión pública que es lo que estoy
haciendo
se siente luchar se jugó rápidamente me
quedan dos preguntas puntuales el manejo
de la pandemia de kobe 19 que ha sido
crítica para todos los gobiernos a nivel
internacional que balance hace usted de
este año de balance de esta crisis
sanitaria muy puntual por favor creo que
felizmente positivo porque se perdió
primero contra la inexistencia de acceso
a las vacunas ustedes saben que más del
80 por ciento ha sido prácticamente
concentrado por casi 20 2010 no más de
10 países en el mundo pero bueno se
resolvió
en su momento se pensó comprar hasta
desde las gobernaciones no sé si de
buena o mala intención pero bueno un
nuevo necesidad hay las suficientes
vacunas y yo creo que si nos enfrentamos
a dos problemas por un lado las
creencias que creo que también es común
a muchos países de américa latina de
evangélicos ya no que hay que
prácticamente han demonizado el hacerse
vacunar y segundo por el porte temas
culturales en algunas zonas rurales del
país pero podríamos decir que el uso se
ha cumplido porque cumplir con la salud
también es cumplir con la economía y
fernanda su opinión al respecto
sólo un pequeño y una pequeña nota con
el tema económico decía hubo del tema de
los precios de las materias primas
efectivamente lo que hay refuerza es que
en estos 14 años del movimiento
socialismo la matriz económica
extractivista colonial ha continuado y
así profundizado y no habido un cambio
de una revolución en el tema de la
matriz económica en el tema de las
vacunas estoy de acuerdo de que
efectivamente hay ciertas ciertos
obstáculos y barreras tanto de tipo
religioso como de creencias pero que yo
creo que también responden mucho a la
falta de información yo creo que debía
haber existido una campaña mucho más
eficiente en el sentido de dotar a la
gente de poder
explicar de qué se trata la vacuna y
todo lo que conlleva eso y además
voy a empezar pues dando el ejemplo no
porque creo que los primeros mandatarios
como lo ha hecho el presidente arce
también lo diría a derecho choquehuanca
de haberse puesto la vacuna y no
fomentar que hay una desinformación al
respecto y creo que ahí en el tema de la
vacuna
y también el tema de la gestión en
cuanto a horarios y cosas que ya son más
administrativas ha sido deficiente si
bueno me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa quiero hacer las
conclusiones con fernanda y con hugo
comienzo con hugo para hablar que sigue
de aquí en adelante para el presidente
arce en que debe enfocarse cuál quiere
usted que son los temas en los que
debería trabajar en lo que le resta de
mandato que son las prioridades para
este país para salir de la crisis
sanitaria que es prácticamente un
panorama transversal para todos los
países de la región
bueno básicamente es centrado en la
recuperación de la economía se ha
planteado la avanzar en la
industrialización en la
industrialización con sustitución de
inversión de importaciones es un anhelo
además de solo países de américa latina
da hace décadas creo que hay condiciones
para llevar adelante esto no hay que
olvidarse sin embargo que hay una
división internacional del trabajo que
determina que unos sean proveedores de
materias primas y otros consumidores a
propósito de la industria atractiva no
es un tema de buena voluntad pero yo
creo que en la medida en que luchar se
fomente más la inversión pública pueda
canalizar inversión privada para
proyectos estratégicos podemos ir
podamos vamos a poder ir resolviendo el
tema del desempleo que ha bajado
contrariamente a lo que dice fernanda ha
bajado en un 50 por ciento respecto a lo
que dejó el gobierno de facto y en
materia de salud en materia de hay
necesidad de una reforma inicial creo
que eso lo vemos como necesario
absolutamente todos oficialistas
opositores etcétera hay que llevar la
revolución
por la justicia y sobre todo creo que
richard se será fuerte y el proceso
boliviano será invencible frente a un
nuevo golpe de estado que es la única
opción que tiene la derecha en la medida
que vaya empoderando más al pueblo a los
movimientos sociales a los trabajadores
patriotas de este país bueno una larga
agenda de trabajo todavía le resta al
presidente garcía y en bolivia fernanda
su opinión sobre los puntos clave en lo
que queda del mandato del presidente
arce en el tema económico yo creo que
más que un tema de simplemente lo que
decía hugo de que hay más países que son
proveedores de materia prima y otros que
no claro para pasa por un tema
ideológico de voluntad política y de
cambio en la matriz económica productiva
eso no es simplemente quedarse estático
ante lo que uno es en el mercado segundo
en el tema salud y yo creo que es
necesario que hay una profunda reforma y
de ello obviamente que va de la mano con
otorgar mayor cantidad de recursos
económicos al sector salud nuestro
sector nuestro sistema tanto público
como privado realmente es absolutamente
deficiente lo hemos visto con esta
pandemia y tiene que que efectivamente
mejorar de alguna manera segundo el tema
de justicia estamos de acuerdo es el
gran pendiente de los últimos 50 años y
directo en va más allá del gobierno del
más hay una falta de justicia y una
instrumentalización de la justicia lo ha
sido y ha sido instrumentalizada la
justicia en el gobierno de transición de
años lo ves ahora de nuevo en el
gobierno de de arce y lo ha sido en el
gobierno de evo morales y en el último
tema que es un tema de orden bueno
también de económico de dinamizar la
cultura la gran deuda que había
prometido el gobierno de arce y que
hasta ahora no ha hecho absolutamente
nada y vencer esa polarización en ojalá
dejáramos de escuchar al gobierno de
voceros de gobierno como hugo hablar del
gobierno de facto porque antes era el
periodo neoliberal y todo tenía la culpa
del periodo de neuroaid aranda ahora
todo tiene la culpa un año de gobierno
de facto según ellos gobierno de facto
en esa narrativa que solamente polariza
entre el fraude
y gobierno de golpe de gobierno de facto
que creo que no hace bien
con la construcción de un país entre
todos bueno se me acaba el tiempo a los
dos les agradezco por haber estado con
nosotros y haber compartido estos
diferentes puntos de vista ustedes
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios en
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]